في بلدتين نورداغ واصلاحيه بولايه غازي
عنتاب بدات شركه الاسكان التركيه المعروفه
اختصارا باسم توكي عمليات اعاده اعمار
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
العمليه بدات هنا ببناء
855 وحده سكنيه في المنطقه ومن المتوقع
تسليمها لاصحابها في غضون سته اشهر
السلطات التركيه قالت انها ستبني 272 الف
وحده سكنيه في احدى عشره ولايه خلال عام
واحد ضمن مناطق بعيده عن خطوط الصدى
وبمواصفات تناسب الطراز المعماري لهذه
المناطق وبشروط موافقه لشروط السلامه من
الزلازل بحيث لا يتجاوز عدد طوابق البناء
الواحد اربعه طوابق كما سيتم بناء الاف
المنازل الريفيه في القرى التي تضررت من
الزلزال
بالتوازي مع عمليات اعاده الاعمار هذه
تواصل السلطات بناء مساكن مؤقته بدلا من
الخيام في مئه وثلاثين منطقه ضمن الولايات
المتضرره من الزلزال
من بلده نورداغ في ولايه غاز عنتاب زيدان
زنجلو